si avons jours le cortège est parti de
l'hôpital saint-louis comment se déroule
la manifestation où est ce que vous êtes
maintenant quelle est l'atmosphère
également
[Musique]
alors actuellement une atmosphère très
bon enfant je suis entre le pont
alexandre iii et les invalides en fait
le gros du cortège arrive en ce moment
il y à vraiment des dizaines de milliers
de personnes
tout ce que nous pouvons voir ici le
cortège n'est évidemment pas encore
arrivé les forces de l'ordre ont bloqué
en fait l'accès au pont donc la
manifestation va se concentrer ici
tandis que ce matin nous étions à
l'hôpital saint louis alors le cortège
des parties de l'hôpital saint louis
mais en revanche des cortèges ont afflué
vers le ministère de la santé et nous
avons rejoint celui de saint louis où se
trouvaient également la maire de paris
anne hidalgo venu en soutien des
soignants je vous propose de l'écouter
il faut réorienter notre économie vers
la santé vers le soin on a bien vu qu'on
a besoin d'eux de tous ces métiers qui
évidemment ne peuvent pas être mis
exactement sur le terrain de métiers
dans lesquels il y a
une compétition une compétitivité on est
dans les métiers du soin dans les
métiers de l'humain et il faut vraiment
que on réoriente y compris la dépense
publique vers ces métiers essentiels on
a bien vu qu'on ne peut pas se passer
d'un système qui soit solidaire
performant qui prennent en compte les
plus fragiles je pense à nos aînés je
pense aussi aux personnes sans domicile
fixe aux personnes isolées
[Musique]
donc vous voyez un monde derrière moi
vraiment vraiment des dizaines de
milliers de personnes avec beaucoup de
slogans pas de retourna à la normale ou
encore blouses blanches colère noire il
faut dire que cette crise sanitaire dans
la santé en fait date de plus d'un an et
les soignants ont des revendications qui
sont les mêmes depuis plus d'un an c'est
à dire une revalorisation de leurs
salaires bien sûr qu'ils sont
actuellement en discussion au c ur de la
santé qui a démarré le 25 mai dernier
mais pas seulement bien évidemment
l'arrêt des fermetures de lits la
réouverture de lit également l'arrêt des
restructurations des hôpitaux des plans
de recrutement de formation
l'art et la tarification à l'acte et
donc de nombreuses de nombreuses
revendications qui vont dans le sens
d'une reprise en main par le personnel
soignant le personnel hospitalier
l'arrêt de cette administration et de la
gestion hospitalière comme celle d'une
entreprise
le plan santé agnès buzyn de novembre
2019 n'avait pas du tout apaiser leur
colère
et aujourd'hui ils le font savoir en
revenant ici par dizaines de milliers
entre les invalides et le pont alexandre
iii
merci beaucoup qu'être sa technique on
vous suivez donc ce cortège